I'm taking 30,000 I use weekly of D3 plus K, but my lab shows lower than desired 43 vitamin D levels.
What could I take? Look at that might be hindered by absorption. I am working on parasites right now. Anything else I could take?
I don't remember your genetics, but there are vitamin D receptor genes, especially the vitamin D, I think it's the tacky gene, that hinders your absorption.
If you have a single or double leal defect of that gene, there's nothing you could do. You're just going to have to take more.
It's just what it is. People that have that genetic defect are definitely looking at their vitamin D levels. If they're not taking vitamin D, their vitamin D levels are usually in the pits.
They have to take a lot of vitamin D. Vitamin D is interesting because people are going to probably have questions about how this person is taking their vitamin D.
Why would a person take 30,000 I use a week instead of taking it? You might be taking it daily. You might just be listed as a weekly dosage.
If so, technically vitamin D is a fat-soluble vitamin, so you could just take one dose per week, technically.
However, if you're taking one dose per week, you're only going to absorb so much, you have absorption sites for these nutrients. You're only going to absorb so much for dose.
Because it's a fat-soluble vitamin, I have said, and most people have said that you couldn't take it any time during the day and you could just take the whole dose. You don't have to split it up into multiple doses.
But people with the vitamin D receptor gene defect that can get their vitamin D levels up, that's a little bit different there.
Split it up into smaller doses throughout the day. You're going to have better chance of absorbing because you have absorption sites that are hindered because of that defect.
So, splitting it up more, taking more, so you're taking 10,000 I use three times a week, you're probably better off taking maybe 10,000 units a day.
Maybe in a product that's maybe 5,000 I use and take one of the more even one at night, that's the way you have to play with it.
I have some, especially some autoimmune patients, that have a double little defective multiple VDR genes and they have to play with it like that and they're taking very high doses to be able to get their units up.